Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
The number is two one nine two. David B.
The other day on one of my
Speaker 2: livestreams, one of our
viewers pointed out, You know, Omicron
Speaker 1: can be. It has an anagram,
Speaker 2: which is moronic.
Speaker 1: I don't know what the
meaning of that was, but the guy, Eric, from
Mass, who told me that he wanted it to mean
Speaker 2: that we should, shouldn't even
Speaker 1: pay attention to Omicron, find
today's caller found an even more pernicious
anagram. Take a listen to this. David, sir, this
Speaker 6: is Corey from Indianapolis. Yes,
I saw in your live stream last week, I
think it was a Super Supertramp mention
that Amy Kron is an anagram for moronic.
Speaker 1: It's it's Omicron, not omni crime.
Speaker 2: But yes,
Speaker 6: I realize something far more sinister.
Which is at the word
Speaker 2: Delta on Micron
Speaker 6: is an anagram for media control.
Right. So I think this might go a little
Speaker 2: deeper than we previously thought. Yes.
Speaker 1: And I checked it out for myself.
It's Delta
Speaker 2: Omicron, not Delta
Speaker 1: Omni Cron, but it is a
perfect anagram for media control.
What it actually means? I couldn't
tell you, but at least conceptually,
some very suspicious stuff going on. We
have a great bonus show for you today.
Speaker 2: Become a member, folks.
Speaker 1: Sign up at join Packman dot com, become
a member and you'll get instant access
Unidentified: to today's bonus.